are there downsides to turning your
passion into a business
who i would say the downside of turning
your passion into a business
is any business
failure feels like a reflection on you i
mean it really um
and sometimes it isn't always you know
it's the marketplace and whatnot
i feel for myself maybe some of the
projects i did might have been before
their time
they were maybe a little ahead of their
time and now
they're perhaps more popular because of
market changes
but yeah i mean the downside is also
it's it's a job that's never done
you know um turning that passion into a
business
is you're kind of always doing business
i mean i'm fortunate to have people in
my life that will remind me like hey
stop working you know you need so
so finding that balance i think is
absolutely critical
so that your passion doesn't overwhelm
every aspect of your life that there are
times that you just turn off
but yeah there there are certainly
downsides and
you'll have to figure out like how to
balance those
are you good with balance um i am
terrible with balance
so i tend to if i do something i
do it uh like over a hundred percent i
can't like
only do an okay job and then what would
usually that leads to for me is i take
too long to do a project
because i want to make it perfect so i
once heard the term
perfliction which is a combination of
the term perfect and affliction
it's like um i i want something to be so
perfect i'll take too long to do it by
the time i get it done it's not
it may have the opportunity
um that it uh would have would have made
it an interesting thing to create
that's that's gone in the past you know
i mean you see that when it comes to the
first person to get a review out of a
movie
right it's not always the best written
review um it used to be back in the day
that a movie would come out and then the
reviews would come out and you'd read
really
thoughtful essays and now there's like a
pressure
on film critics especially to turn out a
opinion or a take as they call it
immediately and i don't know that your
initial take is always
necessarily the right one we used to we
used to
you know ruminate on ideas that um
films that were thought-provoking they
stirred in us and we would
think about those ideas and it sometimes
it takes a little bit of distance away
from having seen a film to process it
and be able to explain it
and that's not happening today it's
about who has the first
take and the first opinions are out and
you'll even see things
trend on social media the first thoughts
on this movie that just came out i mean
if you don't watch
um whatever the binge worry worthy show
is at midnight when it comes out
it's spoiled for you in the morning at 8
00 am when you're reading social media
so i i i find that um
i find that that can can create undue
pressure and i think that
not always the first idea is not always
the best idea um
and i think it's important to really
think about things like that i don't i
don't even know if some of the stuff
the the um the things coming out from
studios
even require that much of that much
thought
but i think that i what i do miss is
that conversation i mean i grew up
reading pauline kale
who i just loved um
i didn't always agree with her but what
i loved is just
how provocative her writing was
um and how thoughtful and how much i
learned every time i read a review
of hers was amazing
and i miss that kind of reverence for
film criticism
i don't even know it's really difficult
to find that these days it's certainly
not
those voices aren't the ones that are
amplified that's
what i'll say why do you think that is
uh
because we consume pop culture too
quickly
you know i mean netflix will drop a show
on friday and everyone will have seen it
by monday and then what's the next thing
um so that's why i think it's important
to have a balanced media diet but in
addition to the balanced media diet you
know
how about a book then a movie then a
podcast
not necessarily you know binging things
constantly
to where you know it almost ends up
being a blur
right um so so i i missed the days of
the thing that was important was the
conversation
and we live in a dangerous time where
you can have the wrong
take on something and
that's kind of dangerous i i i like
ideas that
uh provoke my sensibilities you know um
i like some something a piece of art
that will challenge me
um i know that there's uh you know i i
feel that like there's a lot of um
you know to me fiction fiction is all
about um
uh being able to identify with whoever
or whatever
is on screen whether that person that
i'm seeing in this work of fiction
whether it's a book
movie television show whatever it is i
don't need to be that person i just need
to identify with that person
it may not be my same gender may not be
the same ethnicity or nationality as me
and not speak the same language as i
make not even be human
right but the point of all fiction
is that we identify with the protagonist
and it doesn't have to match who i am in
fact i prefer that it usually doesn't
i mean i remember being mocked when i
was younger
whenever i play video games i always
chose female characters
i don't know why i think i just like to
look at the female form in a video game
but i always chose the female characters
um i i
tend to i'm playing right now the video
game i'm playing and obsessed with
and it's been um wrongly uh
i think mocked for a lot of its
technical issues is the game cyberpunk
which i think is a brilliant brilliant
game it really immerses you
in this you know open world adventure
game
um and i'm playing as a female version
of a character and i
i think it's i think it's amazing i
think that there's um
i i think i think we learn by
identifying with someone
who who doesn't match my my exact
circumstances
i think a lot of this comes from my
mother
um when i was younger and i would just
see whatever mainstream stuff was at the
movie theater
i lived bicycle distance to a movie
theater
where i grew up in royal oak michigan
and i would ride my bike to the berkeley
theater
or the main theater um or the americana
which was a further bike ride but i
would i would i would go see movies and
she would tell me don't just go see
movies that are at the mall theater
go to the art house she encouraged me to
go to the maple theater which was where
their art house theater was
and i saw films that had subtitles
you know i mean i grew up watching a lot
of
touhou monster movies right and and
you know japanese television shows
so i had this you know by the time i was
like in my late teens early 20s
i'd seen a lot of foreign films and a
lot of a lot of
just different types of movies across
the board not just your traditional
big mainstream movies like your star
wars and your alien and
and you know disney cartoons and whatnot
so back to having a balanced media diet
and i think that's important and i think
it's important
and i think i think i know when a
writer's been successful when someone
that
i would not have ever had that
experience where i can just be totally
with that person
um experiencing the world through their
eyes and i'm
i don't look like that person i think
that is really powerful
to be able to create a character
protagonist that anyone can identify
with
so i think that's important to keep in
mind
you